CHELSEA FISCHBACH: Hello.
Today, I'm going
to be showing you
a new add-on for
Google Cloud that
will allow you to seamlessly
import, update, manage,
and share data from Salesforce
using Google Sheets.
My name is Chelsea Fischbach.
I'm from the global
technology partnerships team.
And we're going to
be talking about how
you can use this
add-on to improve
the collaboration of your
team and save time every day
with your Salesforce workflows.
Let's dive in.
Let's start by looking at a
lead report in Salesforce.
You can see here
that it's broken down
by status and by lead owner.
Today, we're going to be
focusing on a use case
where you're at the
end of a quarter
and you're looking to update
your lead data to better
protect your sales for
the following quarter.
This is just an
example though, and you
can use any object that you have
configured in your Salesforce
instance.
Let's go ahead and
jump over to the add-on
to see what this data will
look like in Google Sheets.
So you can see here that we
have a sheet already open.
Let's go ahead and
open up the add-on.
If you don't have the
add-on already installed,
you can get it from
the get add-ons menu.
So let's open up the add-on.
Here, you can see
all the options
that are available for you
to take using the add-on.
Let's start by
pulling in the data
from that report we
were just looking at.
From the reports option, you
can choose a recently run
report or search
any report that's
in your Salesforce instance.
Let's go ahead and pull up
the leads report by status
as we are looking at
in the previous view.
We're going to import this data
to the current sheet, which
will wipe out the data
that we have there.
If you want to keep the
data in your current sheet,
just open up a new tab.
You can see here all the
data from that report loaded
in the sheet.
We can see the
status, the owner.
We can also see a lot
of demographic data
about the lead.
This data can be
really helpful when
you're looking to share data
with people who might not
have access to Salesforce, or
when you're doing those year
end reports and you want to
use all the power of Sheets
to build charts and to just
make better business decisions.
Now let's look at what we can
do if we import a custom query.
From the import option,
you can choose any object
that you have access to in
your Salesforce database.
Let's go ahead and
pull up the lead object
that we were looking
at previously.
You can also, at this point,
load the last data import
settings to quickly start
the process if you previously
were running imports
using the add-on.
With the lead object
selected, let's go ahead
and look at the fields that we
can import from the next step.
Here, you can choose
from the fields that
are available for this object.
Today, we're going to be
importing the state as well
as the status.
And this allows us to focus
on the data set that we're
most interested in achieving.
Let's also import the
company name and the lead ID.
The lead ID is very
important because it
allows us to know what
object we want to update.
Finally, let's filter
the data that we're
going to be updating.
First, we're going
to choose the state.
And we're going to
filter on California
because that's the
territory that we
want to make changes to today.
We're also going to
choose the status.
And you can see here that
we load in the pick list
from Salesforce, so we follow
all of the data formatting
requirements that you already
have configured in Salesforce.
Let's select contacted
to focus on leads
that we've reached out to,
but haven't gotten back to us.
One thing I do want
to point out is
that we do have a
SOQL editor available.
This will allow you
to customize the query
further than is available
in our graphic interface.
Now that we've chosen the data
that we want to import, let's
go ahead and get the data.
You can see here that we pulled
in the state, the status,
the company, and the ID.
These are exactly the
fields that we asked for.
And so we're ready to
start making our updates.
Let's go into status,
and we're going
to choose to unqualify
some of these leads.
So we can edit this just
like any other sheet
in our instance.
And we can use formulas
or functions, whatever is
needed to make those updates.
You can see here that we've
updated several of them
to unqualified.
We're going to go
into the update flow
to see how we can make the
change on the Salesforce side.
Inside the updates
flow, we'll see
that the options
that we have selected
are highlighted in yellow.
This allows us to
know which objects
we're going to be updating
when we make these changes.
It's very easy to make changes.
We just choose a new selection
and hit refresh the selected
range.
You can see here
that the new options
are highlighted in yellow now.
Now that we have the
correct selection,
we can go ahead and confirm the
data that we want to update.
You'll see that we make
some smart decisions to try
to make it easy for you to
make updates to your data
through this process.
If we look at the lead
object that we're updating,
we'll see that it's
already selected, which
we can tell from the ID number.
You can see that there are
three functions available for us
to make changes.
The first is
insert, which allows
you to insert a new record.
The second is
update, which allows
you to update existing records.
And the third is
insert or update,
which will update a data
point if it already exists
or insert a new one.
Let's go ahead and choose
update because that's
what we want to be doing today.
You can see here
that we've already
identified the ID in column
D, and that the results
of our update will
spit out in column E.
And this is just the first
column with no data in it.
So if you want to change
it, you can do that.
Just make sure that there is
no data going to be overwritten
when you make that change.
Now we can complete
the last step
before we make the change, which
is confirming the data that we
want to update.
Today, we're going to unselect
the state and the company data
because we didn't
make any changes.
And it'll just make the
import a little faster
because we do run validation
on every single object
that we update.
So let's go ahead and execute
and see what happens here.
You can see that the data
has been updated successfully
as indicated by the
green message in column
E. If there is an error,
it will be marked in red.
And we'll show you
the error message
that we get back from
Salesforce, which
makes it very easy for you to
be able to troubleshoot the data
as you're making changes.
So there you have it.
Now you can see how
you can seamlessly
import, update, manage,
and share Salesforce data
using Google Sheets.
If you want to check out this
add-on for your organization,
check out the link
below to install it
from the G Suite marketplace.
If you like this video,
please like and subscribe
to see more content like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]